this is every manipulator in Hunter
Hunter ranked by a man on the internet
and we are starting with bass who has a
very good base of a manipulator with her
ability instant lover anyone kissed by
bass becomes immediately infatuated with
her morphe into a type of Love slave who
will take her command for three hours
pretty basic manipulation here simple
condition little bit of control short
period of time it's an ability that's
actually pretty overpowered at lower
levels specifically on those who aren't
nen users think that kind of low level
at higher levels however this ability
becomes pretty neon useless because
non-veterans aren't just going to let
someone kiss them even if it's someone
of how shall we say base's physical
Persuasions opioid game power but
terrible late game Power which is going
to land base smack bang in the Middle
With A Beat here next up we have boki
someone who we know so little about that
his abilities in power section on the
hunt onto Wiki is one line which reads
as follows as a chimera ant boki is
already stronger than the average human
that is an excellent in-depth analysis
right there but bulky to be fair he's
also pretty standard manipulation as a
whole is very tried and tested field you
encounter a lot of the same sorts of
conditions that achieve the same sorts
of results in boki's case he equips a
device to a Target and is then able to
manipulate them using a game controller
it's unknown whether he can control more
than one person at a time in some sort
of two-player mode I suppose all in all
though boki May indeed be stronger than
the average human but when it comes to
manipulation he is nothing but average
and as a result he would be joining base
in the beat here next up is ikalgo who
takes on a more left field version of
manipulation that is if we picture just
left of our field being the graveyard
because the cowgo engages in The Morbid
practice of corpse manipulation from the
inside it's a gruesome but actually
quite rare form of manipulation because
whilst in the body ikalgo can use the
nenability of the corpse which is crazy
because unless post-mortem netas
involved the heartsu should vanish from
the corpse when the target dies so
okalgo actually functions as a more
Macabre form of crawler in fact if he's
so desired hikargo could construct a
body preservation facility and even
build his own library of net abilities
that he can just slip in and out of you
know come to think that it's so rare
that we actually see nen users being
manipulated themselves it's usually like
a standard non-nen using person so I
don't know if it's normal to be able to
use their powers or command them to use
their heart to and in a weird way it's
kind of like a forced activation of
postmortem then to briefly resurrect an
ability for your own personal use and
for that factor alone ikalgo skyrockets
as a manipulator and lands straight in
the atier is what I would like to say
however ikalgo is not a manipulator
according to tagashi's memo ikago is
actually an enhancer despite being
branded as a manipulator in the data
book and also displaying all of the
behaviors of a manipulator so apologies
Mr octopus but you're not actually
allowed to be ranked on this list but I
wanted to talk about him anyway because
he has a pretty interesting use of
manipulation anyway to the poster boy of
manipulation and honestly a man who
carries this entire category on his
rather slender yet malleable shoulders
illumi zoldick is manipulation perfected
he's worked out a system to achieve
maximum output with minimal input I mean
the dude can create an entire Army of
manipulated people whereas the standard
in this Affinity is control of one maybe
two people at a time if you're really
skilled but to that illumi says I'm
gonna just take all the people I can
currently only think of one character in
the series who has manipulated More
Humans than illumi has with an inability
that is there are characters like
pariston who just manipulate the whole
world but that's a different thing but I
also can't think of any other character
who has manipulated more than two humans
at a time which I think makes this
decision fairly simple as illumi is a
definite Hestia but another zeldick has
appeared and get used to it because
we'll be seeing a lot of those today but
this is Carlito the first manipulator
where meeting whose abilities don't
focus on controlling people because
manipulation is such a broad concept you
could use it on anything objects
substances abstract Concepts like music
but despite that the overwhelming amount
of users get funneled into controlling
people not Carlota he instead chooses to
manipulate paper very very deadly paper
as if even a single piece gets stuck to
an opponent then all of the papers will
Target that same area and death via
extreme Papercut will almost certainly
occur Carlito also has this very sneaky
ability to surveil people using paper
cutouts so sneaky that even the Phantom
troop did not pick up on it and whilst
not the Paragon of this Affinity that
his older brother is Carlito is
disgustingly talented for a 10 to 12
year old and is an easy a tier moving
now to a manner but not that the money
there are actually two amaneis in Hunter
Hunter and you've probably never heard
of this one and that's that's for good
reason because this Amana comes to us
courtesy of Hunter Hunter altar of the
DragonVale a game for the PlayStation 2
which features a very blue head 1999 3D
rendered hisoka amane is like a sub
villain of the game but a pretty
incredibly powerful one his ability is
called trembling Melody whereby amane
Rings a little bell and those who hear
the sound of said Bell are able to be
controlled and that is ridiculously
overpowered it very much Breaks the
Rules of nen but in addition it can also
control both living people and dead
bodies manipulators usually need to
choose one or the other but as some form
of restriction Amana can only control up
to two people at once but the power is
still pretty incredibly broken and if he
did actually exist in the world it would
be right up there in the S2 meanwhile we
now have zeldick Mama Kikyo someone only
identified as manipulator through the
hunter hunter Data Book Kikyo has yet to
show us anything literally anything with
the exception of the 1999 anime which
alluded to some sort of ability to do
with kikyo's vision as advisor would
change color or even cut static in
response to kikyo's emotions at the time
as is old dick even one who married into
the family I'm gonna have to give Kikyo
some respect because she's definitely
not going to be a bad manipulator but
without knowing anything else so far I
think the best we can do right now is
plonk her straight in the sea now I
believe it's leecher clock featuring
leech the shadow Beast who serves as a
fantastic example of how to squander
your innate magical abilities leech
manipulates leeches that's it that's the
ability which is interesting because it
means that his entire ability is like
the activation requirement of most
abilities I feel like a more veteran nen
user would structure this leech
insertion as a condition to manipulate
the opponent kind of like what bokish do
with their antennae and needles
respectively militia is pretty happy
stopping halfway but we we are not happy
and so he's going to get smacked with a
great big disappointing D and now for
the zeldick who most aesthetically
resembles leech here is a piggy
millerkey is actually a really difficult
character to rank because like Kikyo he
hasn't shown us anything but unlike
Kikyo we know that miliki is a
world-class trained assassin in fact
apart from his anime sex dolls the only
thing miliki did show us was a bit of a
manga exclusive but he was introduced
smoking a cigar very Bond villain style
and even putting that cigar out on
killua's chest I'm going to give milliki
more credit than Kikyo he is a piggy but
he is a powerful Piggy and so he's going
to sit in the waiting room of mid that
is the beat here to someone who is
anything but mid next up is moral one of
the best General nen uses in the series
but we're not looking for the best
General nin user I want the best
manipulator and I just don't think
that's moral moral's d purple relies far
too heavily on two other affinities
whilst only applying a layer of
manipulation on at the very end like a
coat of lacquer on a smoky chair this
does however make him extremely
versatile so versatile that the hunter
hunter mobugger card game features him
making a kebab which makes me hungry
moral is best described as a utility
manipulator he only really dives into
his Affinity at a surface level because
his interests lay elsewhere and that's
fine especially since that surface level
dive still significantly outranks most
manipulators and is still going to land
moral in a very respectable 80. honzu is
a character that also exists or did
exist past tense despite not becoming a
hunter she tagged along with popcorn and
learned a bit of the old nen
specializing in be manipulation so kind
of like leech but much more better
because the bees were capable of taking
complex commands and so ponzu lands
quite safely in the sea but everyone
please give a round of applause for
Sancho yeah
it's it's on show because he has won the
award of worst manipulator on the list
today Sancho is a character from Hunter
Hunter each one's determination which is
better than known as the game where
karapika wears a very pretty dress and
Sancho is a manipulator who fights very
Joseph joestar style using enhanced
clackers with no tangible evidence of
manipulation at all and whenever a user
ignores their own natural Affinity well
there's only one place for them to go
which means we need to open up the
Castro tier so hop in the bin you
naughty naughty manipulator and you
think about what you've done or more
accurately what you've not done which is
manipulate but here is our true heavy
hitter of the video shirepoof is up next
and if illumi is the poster boy of
manipulation then shirepoof is his
talent producer behind the scenes
manipulating illumi for profit
shayapoo's abilities may as well have no
limits he can control armies of people
he can read your emotions he can
transform his body into any shape in
fact he can just transform into however
many bodies it is that he wants he can
even cocoon people up and gift them nen
abilities he's such a poet manipulator
that the estia is too low for him which
is why in shyapu sauna we are going to
open up the very special violin tier for
him to reside in troop time now and
shall knock is honestly a fairly
disappointing candidate but only when
compared to shirepoof because black
voice is about as good as you can really
hope to get as a manipulator being able
to control up to two people at the same
time with complex commands since it's
pretty good and also even control
yourself to the point where you become a
Super Saiyan an Exquisite specimen of
manipulation and so shanak must be an S
to someone equally as currently dead a
shall knock we also have shikaku someone
who had this very fascinating power to
turn the abilities of others into cards
and then potentially even steal and
wield them I don't know and you know to
be honest we may never know what I do
know is that this is not manipulation
and if it wasn't specifically stated in
the series then I would have thought
that shikaku was a specialist so into
the Castro bin you go shoot McMahon is
also here and look he's a bit of a weird
manipulator I mean shoots a bit weird in
general because he has three entirely
separate hatsu but none of them like you
know synergize with each other hotel
where falcia the disembodied hands and
the power to weirdly insert things into
shoots own hands are a good example of
some someone spreading themselves a bit
too thin the really weird thing is that
Shu can't even use the disembodied hands
as a condition to activate hotel
rafelsia which activates when hands
touch opponents but they need to be
shoot hands shoots hands that are
attached to him so at most all his
floaty hands can do a serve as a bit of
a distraction he's an all right nen user
but not an amazing manipulator probably
even below average and so we're gonna
Mark shoot with a c Sodom is an
interesting fellow who we know nothing
about yet so DTA I don't want to deal
with you and then there's squalor who
practiced dog manipulation I would
personally love this ability it's a
great excuse to have so many dogs all
over the dogs on the condition that you
need to take care of them mate sign me
up although in the grand scheme of
manipulation it's not amazing in fact
it's really not amazing and I can't
bring myself to put this anywhere but
the detail to dessert I now serve you a
zakuru costed a really cool blood
manipulator specifically of his own
blood which is a really hard condition
and as a result it comes with some
pretty amazing power in addition to
deadly deadly Bloods you can even create
great little conscious bloodlets that
roam around and give zakaro information
even so it's like it's still pretty
middling the whole needing to use your
own blood makes it very difficult so I
think that sakuro is a plain old bee our
final Chimera and candidate comes in the
form of zazan who is ridiculous utterly
utterly ridiculous as Queen shot doesn't
just take control of someone but it
transforms humans into permanent animal
hybrid slaves that is a really big thing
for manipulation because most control is
only temporary or involves killing the
person in question this however is a
One-Shot recipe for Eternal slavery
there is a condition that the human
targeted needs to be strong enough to
survive the brutal transformation but if
anything that only works in zazan's
favor ensuring that she only receives
the strongest of slaves while she has
her own body transformation as well and
look if it weren't for shirepoof then
zazan would potentially be the greatest
manipulator but as it is I think she
slots quite nicely into the istio we now
have but one manipulator left so is the
best still to come well at Zushi so so
no because he's a manipulator who can't
even manipulate yet so we're going to
temporarily store him in the castrate
here and that is every manipulator in
Hunter Hunter ranked arbitrarily by a
man on the internet